foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
look who it is
brand new crew today excited we haven't
hit a parlay I was saying this before
the show we haven't hit a parlay since
before Christ and I feel like I've said
that yeah I know but we got to own up to
it Logan we gotta own up to it
um how are you guys feeling though I
don't mean to I don't mean to like jump
in and you know start with the negative
Vibes but I feel like if you get it out
there we can kind of just you know it
feels like I'm getting it off my chest
and then we can start moving forward but
how you guys feeling
I like that cleansing energy you're
bringing to the show right let's let's
get that out of the way right let's
focus on the future the now it won't be
30 minutes of it it won't be 30 minutes
of it but we'll you know just for now
look we got to get the Vibes up like
telling me y'all haven't hit a parlay
before Christ is kind of wild to me so
like hopefully I bring that positive
energy look we're hitting one today
we're hitting one today whether it be
any type of prop any type of money line
whatever it is we're hitting something
today uh yeah we only have 30 minutes of
show so I know that you want to build
like six parlays so we can hit at least
one of course we're only gonna build
we're only gonna build two today but I
mean for the people go ahead um I just
wanted to say I'm not gonna like my
expectations aren't that high right
after after weeks and weeks of pain and
and just sad nights you know texting
Ryan like if this one doesn't hit if
this one doesn't hit like that's lit
it's literally what happened
um so I'm just going for one leg I think
one leg is a win tonight if we get one
uh that's not that's not how
importantly you don't hit a parlay by
only hitting one leg what what kind of
logic is that
it's just you gotta start somewhere now
okay all right sure okay I didn't say we
haven't hit any legs in weeks I'm just
saying we haven't hit a poor lay no you
said that before Christ that's your word
specifically that's before Christ
into my own horn but two two
um I was on the show The last time we
hit up our life that's true by the way
good vibes it's good vibes you're set
you you know you're specifically not
mentioning when that was that was the
All-Star break that's how long ago that
was oh my goodness that was
um all right for people who are people
who are new to the show uh I am
producer Ryan
um but also go by man of the people as
you can see right there uh correctly
finally got that in writing uh all the
way to your right is Logan Geller uh Mr
Bagel unlocks the guy who has hit two
parlays on the show I believe it's two
um and then in the middle we have our
our special expert our special
correspondent today uh Ian Evans Ian
welcome to the show no pressure again
but uh we need to win I'm happy to be
here man let's get into it yes sir all
right guys well we got we got three
three games on the Slate today uh Logan
you're Philadelphia 76ers uh are going
to Brooklyn to take on the Nets we've
got my Sacramento Kings my beautiful
Sacramento Kings uh taking on the uh
golden state
fraudiers is that is that what we're
calling them these days and then wow
defending Chumps win a game win a game
and then the Phoenix Suns and the Los
Angeles Clippers uh but we need you in
the chat to hop in there let us know
what to take
um and get this going but guys uh
I don't know you guys seen anything in
the chat where where are we starting
today
man I'm already seeing Maxi two threes
which is crazy actually no it's not
crazy yeah 30 points Maxi two threes or
less I was about to say he had 30 points
last game Maxi two three seems solid off
the red but what's the value
yeah Maxi t3s you should should
definitely get it I mean yeah
it's lines at two and a half
a two and a half
minus 410 minus 410. it's a leg
it is a leg Yeah it's a leg
um I just wanted to shout out dude I'm
rich man he says we got no job tonight
lfg you know the energy we did
20 points do you see that what do you I
mean like Ryan I'm not sure how you feel
about Russ and betting on Ross
yeah not not good but I will say Kawhi
is out tonight uh Paul George is not
playing so I think I don't hate the idea
of going for for Russ
um we're also Kawhi is not playing
that's the other thing too so right it's
an interesting point yeah hmm look okay
personally I have Westbrook on my like
band this for betting so
it is what it is but yeah you you learn
a large portion of batters in this
country I'm sure
um
yeah this is this is tough because this
Line's at 21 and a half and betting on
Russell Westbrook is not something that
I like to make a habit of personally
um I need better
in the chat Chef Drew in the Chad saying
Steph four plus three is what we think
I like it I do like it
he's got the team on his back I mean
think about it three for 13.
straight right
no way is that four and a half
I kind of like it
I'm not gonna lie I do kind of like it
look where's that home you gotta win
right
they shoot 43s a game I think no I think
this is a great great place to start
four plus is also going to be like minus
yeah you know minus 320.
it's a lag though
minus 320 for four threes though we'll
add it in I'm okay with it it is yeah
yeah we can we can Circle back all right
um B Thompson says last game could be a
blowout
uh in which could be a blowout in which
way are we talking about the Suns
[Laughter]
I I I so here's the thing it's like
whenever a team has a ton of players out
I feel like it's an auto like everyone
wants to bet the other side but that
team who's got all the players out who
are told that they have no chat this is
the playoffs like don't tell a team that
they have no chance to win a game seven
and a half points at home for the
Clippers is a lot
yeah you beat me to it Ryan I was I mean
I was saying Clippers moneyline I'm a
huge Ewing effect guy like you know zag
when everyone else is zigging but
um this Line's already moved right it
was six and a half after the quiet
injury was announced and now it's all
the way to seven and a half yeah
I also like how often do you see a line
swing
four to five points because of one
player being out like that that is super
rare in the playoffs too of all things
yeah like I don't know
I mean do we want to take a side let's
see yeah I'm getting no I'm getting no
takes well wait hold on B Thompson said
Fade All Clippers props they're getting
blown out and stuff at home he's gonna
get four in the first half see but this
is this is my problem with this is that
this is the way everyone in America is
thinking right now you know
right I don't necessarily know if I love
that I will say Luke Swope jumped in
here and said okay bridge is 20 plus
points I like his other one too Powell
15 plus
especially for Kawaii out I don't think
people notice with Kawhi out Norman
Powell hasn't like always had that
opportunity to step up and he's shown it
before
it's an interesting thought because
obviously look if we're going away from
Westbrook 20 plus somebody's got a score
that is true
let's let's just look at the um
like the normal numbers for uh Point
scorers for the clips game like yeah so
so Norm is at 21 and a half uh so 15
minus 800 800 yeah no yeah no so
borderline unbeatable uh let's not do
that yeah that's crazy
absolutely not well let's go to Bridges
plus 20 plus though
because he had the other one but he's 20
plus
I don't know what that's I do want to
look at Terence man at 1.2 actually
we're already here
I mean over 110 and a half sorry there's
a bit of a delay you're about to see me
I'm on the I'm on the 76ers Nets game so
this is no yeah I click snap my fingers
and then there's
um all right so what are we okay okay
Bridges
yeah James Harden is uh over I mean he
had one of the worst playoff games I've
ever seen him play uh last right last
time out
um like how often is he going under 18
and a half points like in his career let
alone in the playoffs
uh I think it's a huge bounce back night
for him
but feel free to shoot me down Celtics
fans
points so I'm either for threes or
assists for him in my opinion
um I'm with Ryan on that because points
there are a lot of people like I was
looking into it a bit today obviously to
generate better of course to look at
every guy's stat split whatever
um a lot of people are on his over today
and as a contrarian better I want to
take his under so but it's like you said
it's James Harden in the playoffs no one
likes rooting for unders so I get where
you're coming from though I think it's a
stay away then I think you know it's
that simple right we're on we're on the
opposite sides here we don't have to
argue and we just move on
uh we completely disregarded Mikhail
Bridges though yeah
who was it like Luke Swope said Bridge's
20 plus points what we think
oh wow
he's at 26 and a half so what is 20 is
going to look like minus 700 we can't
yeah we got it we gotta hit we gotta hit
a regular or a plus money play here
uh yeah Mike Ritter in the chat said I
like hard and assists
Sammy Dixon Wiggins 15 plus I know we're
hopping games hopping around here but he
hasn't had that like big I am the third
option on this team that actually like
was instrumental in last year's
championship or on game yet this series
so like
um
the real time out our boy Ian Evans
can I just can I toss it because we've
gone we've gotten ages without uh adding
another leg in here
I think it might be as simple as I kind
of like kavan Looney over eight and a
half
I think
yeah eight and a half points I think
he's getting a lot of crap for not maybe
being as physical down low as sabonis
and those guys have been on on
Sacramento and I think this is a game
where you know you look for someone like
him to take over without Draymond uh in
the rotation
are we cool with that all right let's do
it why not I love it I like the reason
of your customers
I love it okay
uh talk it edits over on embed rebounds
okay I mean he had like 19 last game
like I'm not I'm not joking
if we're going for that like if we're
following the narrative we've been
following then that means we're not
betting his over rebounds after he just
had like a surreal rebounding
performance 11 and a half
I mean who who else is snagging those
boards down there though yeah yeah
you're not wrong El Bay is jumping in
with a bunch of exclamation point uh
emojis we've got cam Johnson over 13 and
a half points Curry for 30 points better
odds than oh I mean that's a fair point
Curry for 30 points is better odds than
four plus made threes if that's a fact
do you guys feel better about 30 points
or four four plus made threes
I feel like fourth made threes is more
there's more security behind it
but
I can for sure see especially after a
like must win game at home I can see
without Dre obviously you know stopping
people in the chest we don't do that no
more
you know he has a lot to do by himself I
can see stuff going for 30 tonight I
actually can especially with the game
that's usually on the cusp of soaring
over I think it's like what 240 and a
half or something yeah it makes sense
I like that
okay
so okay what we've had to Golden State
props
I don't want to over index here
that's true
um all right so then are we gonna all
right are we doing cam Johnson yes or no
16 and a half
points hmm
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie the volume is going to
be there good points
your volume
well okay yeah for cam Johnson I do like
the value on it was it 13.5 or 16 and a
half 16 and a half 16 and a half
the volume is there
what's the what's the value on it
minus 102. I think we could we're at the
point where I think we can play it down
if we want to do 15 plus let's see what
15 plus is that minus minus 180 we're at
plus 293 and then we can go swap out
Steph four plus for 30 plus points I
like that and then we get to the moment
we've all been waiting for but uh
let's do that all right so 293 three
legs at the moment
okay
Steph 30
okay so we're at plus 390. now what we
can do is we could do to go to 25 plus
we can get it to 265 and then our last
play is going to be most likely a minus
110 play that gets us there
um okay so for the people before we get
to the the last leg we've got kavan
Looney over eight and a half points
Steph Curry 25 plus points
and then cam Johnson 15 plus points now
Ian you're our special expert here
you're you're the the man we're leaning
on today to take us home fourth leg is
gonna be your best bet
my best bet today I got a lot of preps I
got a lot of props
um the one that I absolutely love today
Spencer Dinwiddie over seven and a half
assists
when it comes to games where
there was with the Mavericks or even
when he was with the Wizards obviously
you know there's that whole thing with
coups or whatever that's besides the
point when games where it mattered most
he found a way to play make going over
seven and a half eight and a half or
nine and a half almost I I want to say
it was like eight of his last nine games
I can see him doing that same thing
today with my cow who he somehow figured
out has a bag after getting traded from
the Suns he did it in like once he got
traded did the same thing once he got to
Brooklyn in the games that he did play
in he's been playing making ever since
he got to Brooklyn and pretty much
everywhere else in playoff situations I
can see him going over seven and a half
today I don't know what it was at 148
yeah 148.
I like that it gives it gets us to plus
487 I also saw people uh getting on me
in the chat about kavan Looney points
and asking for reasons I don't like
instead
I did not like it ask you for rebounds
instead and he's at 11 and a half I
don't know if we can play around with
that a little bit and get it to like
they wanted 10 or 8. uh we can't no we
can go oh we can go over eight and a
half maybe but
I don't know what do you guys think do
you want to stick with the points or go
with the rebounds
for Looney we're talking about yeah yes
um I
I'm looking at locks underwater in the
chat that's tough
I don't want to move away from kavan
Looney fully because I love the way the
confidence you came in with I think
there's a play there yeah I think there
is a play there yeah
but Jordan pool 15 plus
points
is speaking my language you speak in my
language locks underwater I don't know
man you see uh he he carries whenever
the dubs are kind of missing somebody
and
I don't know if you haven't seen that
performance from him
yeah instead of Curry he said instead of
Curry 25 plus oh I think that's gonna be
it that's gonna be a no for me yeah
I I don't I don't know Chad is not
liking the kavan play right now but I
feel like there's some value with with
some of the stuff with some of the props
that they're giving this is I don't know
Ryan this is an opportunity for you to
like look inward are you truly the man
of the people right like are you gonna
yes
are you gonna listen to the the people
saying take Looney out
take Looney out I'm not seeing any of
that
kavan Looney 10 or 12 rebounds I I'm
okay with taking uh
can we take 11 can we take 11 we
this is Ryan's character development as
a man of the people he's just he's
unsure right now I liked the points
though I really did
I I think it's maybe too many we're
going too many points for Golden State
all right let's go God this is never as
easy as I think it's gonna be
hmm
gets hard it gets harder every time all
right elfay says elbe says W Ryan I
don't know so he keeps the points yeah I
say let's keep the points let's keep it
let's keep it let's keep it yeah so then
this is going to be anything I never
ended yeah right never all right so then
this is going to be our our final parlay
here it's gonna be Steph Curry 25 plus
points kavan Looney over eight and a
half points
cam Johnson 15 plus points and then the
Ian Best Bet of the day last leg Spencer
Dinwiddie over seven and a half assists
to break to bring us home
four legs plus 477 on FanDuel
um
that's where like you look at this and
you say that this is gonna hit this
they're finally gonna break the curse
you're gonna want to be with us when we
when we make history Ian's with us he
wanted to make history today so go over
to FanDuel and if you've been watching
this show and you're like you just been
here for Vibes right you're you know you
show up every every week and you're like
oh this is a fun show to watch but this
week you're like actually I think I want
to go bet it and you're new to FanDuel
there's a new customer offer bet five
dollars and get a hundred and fifty
dollars guaranteed in bonus bets
guaranteed guaranteed it doesn't matter
they win or lose
there's free money I hadn't created a
FanDuel account yet so
it's unfortunate I know I wish I knew
about this too but 150 guaranteed so
when we come back next week you can use
the bonus bets on that and we'll win
again
so that's that yes I'm with it I love it
I just want to say real quick Spencer
dimly has been averaging over nine
assists ever since he came to Brooklyn
[Music]
that's big brain stuff right there man I
love it I love it all right so one last
time for the people before we move on
here Steph Curry 25 plus points kavan
Looney over eight and a half points cam
Johnson 15 plus points and Spencer
Dinwiddie over seven and a half assists
plus 477 four legs and now we move on to
the the bet that is truly yeah
screenshot sorry no there it is there it
is now now you screenshot now you
screenshot so if I see any comments that
are oh what's the parlay what's the
parlay there's no excuse for it there's
no excuse for it it's right there
screenshot use your resources yes
exactly exactly I can't I can't
constantly be feet I can't keep reading
we're gonna be here forever
um all right so the bet that has been
sweeping the nation if you haven't heard
of it by now it is both teams to score
in the first minute I mean is there a
better sweat than the first 60 Seconds
in a basketball game and rooting for
both sides right whatever you could have
a money line you could have a player
prop but in this one you get to come
together grab hands in the middle and
say both teams do your thing
um Logan I know this is you brought this
to my attention today so uh if you want
to start us off I mean
I just I just want to say that I think
like the plus sign is next to the wrong
number here
are you kidding me
both teams to score yes you can have one
leg of your parlay ticked off within 20
seconds quick turnover
quick quick drive to the rag we've got
the ball back get it to Dinwiddie who's
going to get an assist passage to cam
Johnson he's gonna hit a three like look
at like it's all their Synergy we're
working together the parlay is going to
cash along with both teams to score in
the first minute of this game
King's Warriors you want to jump in here
for your King's Ryan uh I will say this
the lion is giving me is I'm questioning
it a little bit because there is no
defense for either of these teams like I
think I I my my cap on this would be the
same as what you just said Logan it
feels like the plus sign is next to the
wrong one I don't know how this is I
like yes they don't play defense they
don't
they don't that's just that's really
what it is like the only the Golden
State played Super like so poorly in the
last game and the Kings kept letting
them back in the game because they did
not slide on D they they legitimately
could not play Health defense it's like
oh you beat the first guy here's the two
points like that's that's what it was
like yes so I I love this in this game
all right Ian
Sons Clippers yes is plus 124 no is
minus 174. so let me do a little bit of
a backstory for you guys I degenerately
bet you know both teams to score in the
first minute for every single game so
far that's how much of a degenerate I am
okay so I like just to let you know how
these have gone in these three games so
far for the Sixers Nets it hit in the
first game not the second game in the
Kings warriors did not hit in the first
game but it hit in the second game so
you kind of gave me the kind of tricky
one in the sun's Clippers it hasn't hit
yet like for the over for yes oh we love
that we love that so do we go with yes
like do we go with triple yes is this
what we're thinking
I don't know I yes Logan
I think it might be a triple yes
I I think it might be a triple yes I
think it gets the ten to one with the
triple yes yes
[Laughter]
honestly not looking at it this is my
kind of parlay right I mean three legs
ten to one that's it all plus money I
mean I I personally love it as well like
again it's a degenerate parlay but when
it hits It's the Most satisfying thing
ever because there's people there's
gonna be people like whether it be in
the app or you know even friends like
dude this isn't gonna hit but what if it
does like right the most wisest words
I've ever heard when it comes to betting
the best parlay is always tomorrow's
parlay so who cares just just put it
down yeah why not why not
I have some room on this wall behind me
I feel like maybe I'll frame that and
and put that up
I'll get you like one of those nice big
like like behind me a parlay like on the
canvas and you can yeah you can hang it
up there in the in the studio it'd be
really nice touch dude Logan you're the
you're like that yeah you're the T-shirt
parlay guy I don't know if you've got
any I know you're usually Sharpies I'm
not gonna say why it's Sharpies and why
you're not printing them out that would
be disrespectful of me I'm not gonna go
there I'm not gonna go there why you're
not printing out the t-shirts
but no it's authentic it's authentic to
write on it's authentic I love it right
right right right that's why we do it
um yeah uh if this does hit though if
this does hit though I think the three
of us need some T-shirts with the Parlor
I think so oh that's awesome
from the hand from the hand of the
T-shirt parlay man same Sharpie and all
you'll get them don't worry I was I was
asking for maybe a little bit more of a
printed t-shirt but we we can we can
offline there we'll we'll figure it out
I know they're expensive men just get
get a whole frame and everything I love
it yeah
um all right do we want to hit we can
hit some chat here for a second
um let's get into the chat all right we
still got Westbrook 20 plus in the chat
I mean yeah stop
just like for three segments past that
the show
like
yeah
my guy elbe said might swap uh kavan for
son's money line listen you do what you
want but Kavon if I can remember
correctly cavan was minus 105. son's
money line I think it's like minus 300
you're not getting nearly the same juice
that's right that's yeah I mean you you
do what you got to do uh Zippy says it's
not too late for Westbrook no it is too
late it is too late again did we not
hear the part of the show when I said me
and Logan more than half of the country
has banned this man from their betting
list no I'm not doing this well no I'm
not doing this it's not happening which
maybe is why the numbers so hot I don't
know maybe we should maybe we should
have thought about zigging when everyone
was zagging but we have the parlay
already set
um
Shaquille O'Neal spent spelled with
k-n-e-e-l clever sure said Ian is the
guy
I love baby all love
you will be the guy when when Spencer
dinwid over seven and a half hits
that'll be and and when the uh both
teams to score on the first minute
parlay also hits exactly yes there you
go I'm so excited for that I can't wait
I'm really excited for that yeah just
sit down turn the TV on and know if my
if we have legs or if we've lost yet
again yet another parlay uh within 30
seconds it'll be great every minute yeah
uh smoke gas said uh LBJ for 35 Plus
after all that talk from Brooks
saying I don't respect anybody unless
they give me 40. smoke ass
the Lakers don't play tonight yeah
that's tomorrow
you know tomorrow the other night yeah
but the Lakers are still not today like
smoke gas I love you and I love when you
come on you give us your plays
but it's the wrong day brother it's the
wrong elbe said might swap Kavon with
Warriors money line they are down too
well do you think they're due for a win
I do think I mean we already have the
parlay like said yeah what
Food For Thought listen mine no I I
think they're 100 going the Golden State
Warriors tonight that being said I bet
Kings plus uh six and a half
yes and don't forget Logan we have we
have Kings to win the series
we have Kings to win the series and our
pla that Ryan and I built on the side we
only build parlays that might hit on
this side
well because the second we put it out on
the air it's a it's a guaranteed loser
that's kind of how I've that's kind of
how I've realized this goes there was
somebody a few weeks ago who called us
uh Sports books number one uh donators
and
um that has lived rent-free in my head
so oh wow that's that's we're not
putting that one that's tough not
putting that one on a shirt that's not
mine no no we are not absolutely not we
are not um oh my goodness but all right
guys I think uh we let's review the
parlay one more time and then uh and
then we can we could peace out and get
out of here uh Steph Curry 25 plus
points kavan Looney over eight and a
half points cam Johnson 15 plus points
and then the Ian Best Bet Spencer
Dinwiddie over seven and a half assists
plus 462 over on FanDuel uh go tell us
and then the both teams to score in the
first minute we have yes in every single
game yes and they're all plus money
three legs plus 10 44. it doesn't get
better than that
really doesn't
all right guys it's been a blast uh Ian
appreciate you jumping on Logan of
course you know you know you're I think
your success rate on this show is like
close to 70 when you come on so let's
keep that going here
um I am the man of the people producer
Ryan right next to me is Ian Evans next
to him is Logan Geller this has been a
time thanks for jumping on with us let's
go catch some bets peace godspeed
manifest let's do it
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
thank you